I I do think it's a very tough fight for
Henry cejudo at his age if you look at
the odds odds are not on his side at his
age and going for a title shot
um I will I would probably put my money
on aljo in this I'll probably take aljo
I'll give you my picks right now I'm
taking the dogs if I wanted to be on the
side of Kosh and make sure I'm right so
you guys you know take my my pick
serious I can do that that's what every
other show you watch is gonna do that's
not what I do I if you want to make
money I like Steamroller as a underdog I
like Chrome Gracie I would take Muhammad
as a dog and I'll take Al Joe
those are all dogs I'm taking all dogs
here so I'm taking Matt crone
Muhammad and aljo
those are my picks
great card though one Championship great
card taking DJ in that main event you
know I'm taking Mikey no I'm taking Soul
ditch you know what I'm saying yeah you
know I'm taking Stanford yes